[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday
a one-way road to freedom that's how
boris johnson described his roadmap for
easing lockdown restrictions this week
millions will be hoping it's not another
false dawn and then even if it takes a
few months we genuinely
are on the way back to some sort of
normality
but of course the road to freedom could
contain a few bumps and the biggest of
all perhaps the economy
many businesses are still fighting to
survive more jobs will surely be lost
and the public finances are
in a dire state after record levels are
borrowing during the pandemic the
chancellor will begin laying out his
plan for the
economic recovery in the budget on
wednesday and the stakes really couldn't
be higher
well in a moment we will be focusing on
that budget the man who's going to be
delivering it the
chancellor rishi sunak will be here in
the studio very soon
his opposite number from labour the
shadow chancellor annelise dods will be
joining us too
the west midlands mayor andy street will
be giving his view
and will also be talking to anasawa the
man elected this weekend to lead the
labour party in scotland
plus i've been on the road to find out
what struggling businesses want to see
in that budget but first
as the country looks forward to the
covered crisis hopefully easing
in the coming months the dangers for the
chancellor will only increase
in many ways managing the economic
recovery is the moment of maximum danger
for risky sunnah something he's probably
well aware of
as he prepares for his second budget on
wednesday and i'm pleased to say the
chancellor joins us now thank you very
much for being here
with us um i'm keen to talk about the
budget of course um but just
firstly on the roadmap that we saw which
feels like the the way out for the
economy as well as
of the pandemic and i understand of
course you say that it's going to be
driven by data
not dates so does that mean if the data
is better than expected
that roadmap could happen quicker than
you've laid out
well what the prime minister laid out
was a series of steps
with appropriate gaps between them for
us to understand the impact of each step
and as he said what we want is a
cautious but irreversible
approach that's why we've taken the
approach
that we have and those will be the
earliest
dates that we think we can do the
various things that we've we've laid out
but we're doing everything we can to
make sure that it is hopefully
irreversible that's what we want to see
what i understand is if you say it's
driven by data and not dates but you say
it can only move in one direction as
it can only slow down but it can't speed
up then it doesn't really feel like it
is driven by data it feels like it's
driven by dates
well it's good it wants to be cautious
right because i think what we want and
as you talked about businesses before in
your opening what businesses don't want
is a stop
start approach to this we want to know
that it's a one-way road
and that's why it's cautious we've given
the earliest of dates
to give a sense of uh timing and a sense
of direction
and then obviously we might have to
adjust those if things are not going
exactly as we would like but
the early signs are promising we're
seeing great news
with the rollout of the vaccine not just
the take up of it but also the efficacy
of the vaccine the data that we're
getting is showing us that it is working
so i think that should give us all a
sense of confidence and optimism about
the future
that we can make progress on that road
map and as you said hopefully slowly get
our lives back to normal i'm sure so
many businesses are going to be hoping
to feel that confidence in optimism but
of course it's been a really difficult
time for
so many uh different businesses across
the uk you're announcing a new grant
scheme
just tell us a bit more about what the
idea is yeah well we know that
particularly businesses in the
hospitality leisure accommodation and
retail have been
affected by the restrictions and they're
still closed
in the coming weeks and will only open
slowly and still with some restrictions
we want to support them as they reopen
want to support them to keep staff to
pay bills
and that's why we're launching the
restart grants which we paid
in april worth five billion pounds in
total but up to
eighteen thousand pounds for a
particular hospitality business on the
larger side
and those will be paid through local
authorities to over 650
000 business properties across the
country to help them as we reopen and
get our economy going again
a lot of the businesses who can be
affected by this are high street firms
are you worried about the long-term
consequences of the fact everyone's been
shopping more online during the pandemic
and is this something that you might be
looking at to try and help the high
street and perhaps
looking at targeting some of those
online companies well that's why we've
put in place this this grant scheme the
restart grants because
businesses that have been forced to
close multiple times over the past year
actually employ millions of people and
what i care about is protecting as many
jobs
as possible by supporting those
businesses to protect those jobs that's
what this grant will do they've been hit
in a way that online firms haven't been
frankly
and that's why we we've put something in
place previously called the digital
services tax which i announced at last
year's budget
which is a tax on online marketplaces
we're working with our international
colleagues actually this year
and i'm doing that through the g7 and
the g20 group of finance ministers
to find an international agreement on
taxing digital companies
but look our high streets are really
important that's why we have the high
streets and towns fund that's why we've
done planning reforms
that's why we're now providing generous
cash grants to help those businesses get
back on their feet keep their staff
as we reopen in the coming weeks and
months okay now when i announced you're
going to be on the show
today i was inundated with questions
from people
and one of them is from andy now he says
i work at manchester airport the
aviation industry has been badly
affected by covid
will the furlough scheme last for a
while longer student of course to finish
in april but the restrictions are not
going to lift all the restrictions
until june well when it comes to support
in general
i said at the beginning of this crisis
that i would do whatever it took to
protect people families and businesses
through this crisis
and i remain completely committed to
that the prime minister
in in the road map set out a path for us
to recover and reopen
and i want to support people and
businesses along that path
it's going to be extensive i'm not going
to comment on specific policies but i
want to make sure people realize that
you know we are going to be there to
support them and if you look at our
track record
we went big we went early and there's
more to come next week with regard to
airports for example
they had a generous break on their
business rates over this past year
that furlough scheme i know has been
helpful for many people employing that
industry i know how difficult
it is and i want them to have the
reassurance that we are here to keep
supporting people
as we reopen the economy but andy wants
specific reassurance
on the furlough scheme well wednesday is
budget when we'll set out the next step
of everything but andy and others
you know hopefully will have had
reassurance over the past year knowing
that we've done
absolutely everything we can to support
businesses families and people through
this crisis
and we remain as you can see by today's
announcement uh supporting our high
street businesses committed to that goal
once restrictions are eased is that
going to be the time to start winding up
some of the support packages you're
talking about
well i think it's right that the support
aligns with the roadmap so the prime
minister's roadmap has a path
on which we will slowly reopen our
economy and we want to make sure that
our support
supports people along that path and
that's what you will see on wednesday
and we've been doing this for a while
our support has been adapting and
evolving
remember back in july last year i set
out our plan for jobs
that's because protecting and supporting
creating jobs is my number one economic
priority
tragically three quarters of a million
people have already lost their jobs
i want to make sure that all of those
people have fresh hope and opportunity
so this weekend we also announced that
we are doubling the
bonus that we provide to companies to
hire new apprentices for example up to
three thousand pounds
for apprentices of any age it's an
example of us continuing to adapt and
evolve policy to support
people into work and one more question
this is from petrina
she wants to know are you going to be
removing the 20 pound a week increase in
universal credit
yeah again katrina budget on wednesday
is a there's a place where we'll set out
all of our
next stages of our response but i know
that that uplift has
has made a difference to people over the
past past 12 months it's you know one
part of a comprehensive plan that we've
put in place to protect people
you know particularly those on low
incomes and looking forward
we can point to the fact that we're
increasing the national living wage next
year by above inflation which will mean
almost a 350 pound pay rise
for someone working full-time you've
said you touched on the difference it
makes people they would it not be unfair
to remove that uplift if you as you call
it before
the restrictions end as i said the prime
minister's road map
sets out of path and we want to support
people along that path and
people will see that on on wednesday
whether it's with the national living
wage increase
support in with new apprenticeships
whether it's support for businesses it
will remain committed to supporting
businesses families
and people through this crisis now you
say you want to
support people through the crisis of
course that comes at a cost uk
debt now around 2 trillion pounds how
worried are you
well we've just been talking about the
support that we've put and put in place
as a result of chronovirus but
chronovirus has also just had an
enormous
toll on our economy and i want to level
with people
about that about the problem that causes
and the challenges that it presents us
with
and be honest about our plan to address
those okay
um i mean some would argue that you know
interest rates are low we should be
relaxed about borrowing money because we
can do so
cheaply at the minute i mean to look at
joe biden for example in the u.s
with this big stimulus package that he's
announced is that a
view that you subscribed to well we've
gone to stimulus again just worth
bearing on we've spent almost 300
billion pounds over the past 12 months
supporting people
so we we are doing that and we will keep
doing that but we've got each other yeah
we've got regard to the future as you
said i think we do have a challenge in
our public finances and if if we don't
do anything
borrowing will continue to be at very
high levels even after we've recovered
from covert debt will continue to rise
indefinitely and that's not a good
situation for a couple of reasons
i mean firstly if you think about how
i've been able to respond during this
crisis
i think generously and boldly and
comprehensively that was only possible
because we
entered the crisis with strong public
finances i want to make sure when the
next shock
comes along whoever's sitting here can
do the same thing that i've done
they need strong public finances to do
that that's austerity then
secondly you talked about interest rates
and you're right interest rates you know
have been at very low levels which does
allow us
to afford slightly higher debt levels
but that can always change and we're
seeing that in the last few weeks
people will know about that when they
think about their own mortgages for
example
you know when interest rates change what
can i afford so we have to be acute
to that possibility and thirdly we also
want to deliver on our
commitments to deliver strong public
services and i want to be able to do
that as well so for all those reasons
you know making sure that we have strong
public finances is important
that's why i want to level with people
about the challenges and set out our
plan to address that you mentioned the
risk of increasing interest rates are
you worried then like in the summer
there's a lot of pent-up savings for
example
interest rates could actually rise and
have a serious impact on the public
finances
well in terms of you're right there are
pent-up savings and as we saw
last year as the economy reopened
we saw that spending come back which is
great and we want people out and about
that will help drive our recovery
i think the other thing that i'm i'm
keeping an eye on there was also
business investment
that has taken a toll over the past 12
months and we want to see business
investment also playing its part in
driving our recovery
and you can rest assured that we'll be
looking at every possible way to support
our economic recovery
so at what point then do you start
looking
at trying to bring some of that debt
down this budget
this year at what point well i i think
there are two things one is we want to
keep supporting the economy right
because of the restrictions are still in
place
there's a road map over which they will
lift and we'll provide support for
people along
uh that path and i remain committed to
that whether it's with apprenticeship
bonuses support for high streets as
we've seen today or the various other
things that we're doing
we announced the creation of a new
national infrastructure bank as well uh
this weekend which will help drive our
recovery
but it's important for the reasons we
talked about to also have strong public
finances over time but this is not
something that's going to happen
overnight
given the scale of the shock we've
experienced the scale of the damage
this is going to take time to but when
does it when does it start though
because i
i know obviously it's not going to start
before june you've been very clear about
supporting people until that roadmap
ends but
should we be expecting for you to be
focusing on rebalancing of those public
finances
in the near term in this year well i
think what what you want and what i want
to deliver is support for our economy
now when it needs it support along that
road map helping to drive our recovery
but also leveling with people and being
straight about the challenges we face
over time because of the shock
coronavirus has caused our public
finances and making sure that we're
clear with people about
an honest and fair plan to address that
and i think those things are both
compatible
okay well let's talk about the honest
and fair plan to address that a lot of
people
will be saying that one way to address
that is through tax rises we currently
have the lowest levels of
corporation tax in the g7 19
we're still going to have the lowest
amount of corporation tax by the end of
this parliament
yeah sophie unfortunately it's difficult
for me to talk about specific
tax policy and specific taxes i know
it's frustrating for you it'll be
frustrating for your
viewers but the simple reason for that
is taxes obviously have an impact on
businesses and on market
and it's not appropriate for a
chancellor to talk about those outside
of a bike could it rise though
again it's not i can't talk about
specific tax policies it's
unfortunate but appropriate that we we
leave that for budget so i apologize for
that well let's in that case talk about
your last manifesto then because in your
last manifesto
you said this we will not raise not this
this is the tax rate so we will not
raise the rate of
income tax vat or national insurance
that was
the election manifesto that you stood on
are you going to stick to that promise
again you're you're asking me to talk
about specific tax policy and
unfortunately i'm asking if you're going
to break an election promise it's a bit
different isn't it no well we're just
we're a couple of days in advance of a
budget and again tax policy is
appropriately dealt with that at the
budget
um okay um are you considering
some people there's reports on the
papers today that you're considering
freezing
the amount at which people start paying
the basic rate of income tax and the
higher rate of income tax now that
wouldn't be breaking the pledge
but it would be stretching the pledge
wouldn't it i think
look again i can't i it's really
difficult for me to talk about specific
tax policy for the reasons that i've
i've explained but taking a step back
you know this is about as i said
appreciating the damage that chronovirus
has done to our economy
recognizing the scale of the support
that we've put in place
ensuring that we protect the economy
through the rest of the crisis support
people and businesses as we emerge
through
the road map but also making sure that
our public finances over time are
returned to a strong position
so that we can respond to the next
crisis so that we're protected as
interest rates may or may not
change and that we can deliver strong
public services
that's what that's what we're going to
do and as as conservatives
i think people elect us to deliver those
things and and i think that's important
i understand you don't want to talk
about specifics ahead of a budget
but you know you've been chanted for a
year you've been firefighting mo that
whole time with a pandemic i'm just
trying to get a sense of what
you actually are as a chancellor what
the vision is you know are you
you know a low tax chancellor do you
want to cut
taxes to help the recovery to increase
investment are you someone who wants to
see a stimulus like joe biden
are you someone who wants to increase
taxes because you've got an eye on the
state of the public finances you know
what what is the sort of rishi's tsunami
vision
well i'm a conservative and i believe in
in lower taxes
look what's happened to us over the past
12 months we've faced a shock
unlike that which we've ever seen before
and it required
a very particular response from
government it required government and me
to do things that i never imagined i
would have to do that no government
would probably imagine they have to do
but i think i believe that was the right
thing to do
you know i stood up and said i would do
whatever it takes to protect people and
businesses through this crisis
i meant it and that's what we've
delivered over the past 12 months an
unprecedented amount of support
for families and the economy at a very
difficult time i mean to keep doing that
and deliver on the things that we were
elected to do whether that's
50 000 more nurses 20 000 more police
officers 40 new hospitals
to invest in infrastructure all around
the country to level up opportunity
those are the things people elected us
to do and they elected us to be
responsible with their money and that's
what i plan to deliver
you say you believe in low taxes now
according to the sunday times you told
mps last week
that you want to plug the 43 billion
pound black hole
so you can cut taxes in a pre-election
budget i mean that sounds an awful lot
like playing politics with the recovery
did you say that
no i think in terms of specific numbers
i think it it it's a bit hard for anyone
to be precise about specific numbers
did you say that to them no i don't
recognize that that figure actually
the being specific so specific with
numbers at this stage when there's so
much economic uncertainty
i don't think actually anyone could uh
could do that that wouldn't be the
that wouldn't okay so you don't
recognize the figure but did you tell
mps last week
that you want to cut taxes in a
pre-election budget i i i would like to
be able to keep taxes low for people in
general that i'm a conservative and i
believe in that
but i want to deliver our promises that
we
made to the british people that we would
be responsible with their money that we
would look after the nation's finances
and we would deliver strong public
services and given
the shock that chronovirus has caused us
i think it's right for me to have acted
in the way that i have provide the
support that we are providing and will
continue to provide it sounds like
it sounds like you did say this that you
would you know try and rebalance the
the finances in the short term so you
could cut taxes for pre-election but i
think it sounds like you did i think in
the short term what we need to do is
protect the economy and keep supporting
the economy through the road map
and over time what we need to do is is
make sure that our public finances are
sustainable and that's what we've been
talking about that leveling with people
about what that's going to require that
that isn't going to happen overnight
that is going to be
work that takes time given the scale of
the shock
that we've experienced but if you're
asking me you know
do i want to deliver low taxes for
people of course i do
um the difficulty of course in some ways
is going to be not the the moment at
this time when you've got the highest
approval ratings in in cabinet you're
giving money away you're trying to
support people through the pandemic
but it's going to be the rebalancing are
you worried that once you have to start
taking money off people then you know no
amount of those slick instagram posts
are going to keep those approval ratings
up
you know i'm not worried about that
right what i'm worried about is just
trying to do the right thing at the
right time
and be honest and straight with people
about what we're doing and why we're
doing it and hopefully do things in a
way that's fair
and commands broad support that that's
what you'll see on wednesday and that's
what i've tried to do throughout this
crisis
talking about your sort of your
throughout the crisis as i said you know
you're the most popular person
in cabinet according to the polls but
you know when it comes to covert some
would argue
you've got quite a lot of things wrong
you've been on the wrong side of the
argument
according to the university of warwick
your eat out to help out scheme caused
a significant rise in new infections and
accelerated the pandemic into its second
wave
last september you said that we must
learn to live with it live without fear
and according to the oms in september
what 18 000 people more than 80 000
people have died with covered on their
death certificate if you've got some
things wrong
well with regard to eat out to help out
actually i think there's there's many
different studies and
i don't agree with that uh because if
you look at it actually
areas where eat out help out was used
the most for example in the south west
where the slowest to see any rise in
infections and actually had very low
infection rates
and almost all other major countries
have had rises
over the autumn and winter and they
didn't have eat out to help out so i
think it's a bit odd to
ascribe causality in that way and what i
was trying to do
and i think is the right thing to do is
try and protect the over two million
people that work in the hospitality
industry
they're often lower paid younger women i
think as a matter of social justice
those jobs are really important for us
to try and protect and that's why
today we're announcing five billion
pounds of grants to help those
businesses
keep those jobs that will always be very
important to me
and as we look to the future we will
have to learn to live with coronavirus
vaccines we're going to roll them out
and and we will have a very
successful rollout of them and they are
proving to be really effective which is
fantastic
you know but no vaccine is perfect and
in the same way that we live with flu
you know we will have to learn to live
with chronovirus that's something that
i think doctors would agree with it it
will become something that we learn to
live with like flu so i think that is
actually
the right way to approach it um just
finally well i've got you i just want to
ask you about
shimmy and bagan and she left the uk of
course to join islamic state when she
was a school girl
the supreme court recently ruled she
can't return to the uk to fight that
decision to strip her of her citizenship
now i don't want to talk about the
rights and wrongs
of her case if she should be a citizen
or not but you know her
the government was able to take away her
citizenship because her parents were
born
abroad that they were born in a
different country so someone whose
parents have been born in this country
had done exactly the same thing as
shamim bagan she wouldn't have been
treated
in the same way is that fair are you
comfortable with that well i think i'm
i'm glad that the supreme court has made
a made decision that they have and i
think they've
they've opined on the matter and that's
probably the right way for it to be
but do you comfortable the fact that she
would be treated differently if her
parents hadn't been
born abroad well i think the supreme
court decision supported what the
government
was trying to do and i'm glad that it
has and i think that's the right
decision in this case that we've been
able to reach
okay wish you no thank you very much
great to have you on the show today
thanks very much
that was uh oh there you go sorry
outright rishi sunak uh there well let's
now talk to the person who is going to
be responding
first to his budget on wednesday that is
labour's
shadow chancellor annelise dodd thank
you very much for being on the program
and we just heard from the chancellor
what are you hoping to see in the budget
well it's a real pleasure to be here
just to be clear it's actually the
leader of the opposition who will be
responding to that budget but obviously
as a whole labour team
what we want to see from the chancellor
on wednesday
is an absolute determination to protect
jobs
and businesses in the uk and to secure
our recovery that
must be at the front of the chancellor's
mind not any party political
considerations about what's best
for the conservative party at the next
general election but he needs to focus
on what's right for our country right
now to secure that recovery
there are lots of reports that rishi
sudak is going to be increasing
corporation tax um something that you
said that you won't support
why is it then that you don't want to
see a rising corporation tax now but in
2019 you stood as a shadow treasury
minister on a manifesto calling for
higher corporation tax
well look over the last 10 years the
conservatives have pulled our country
further and further away
from the mainstream on corporation tax
and actually that's not
resulted in additional investment we've
seen investment
actually being rised at a lower level in
the uk compared to many other
countries what the conservatives are
doing now though isn't setting out that
long-term plan to rebalance
our tax system in fact they're kicking
the can down the road when it comes to
business rates reform
what they seem to be focused on doing
particularly the chancellor
is trying to get any tax changes out of
the way
quickly get them out of the way so that
they can then have a general election
when they can cut taxes now instead they
should be
focused all of the time on building
jobs and businesses in our country so we
can secure that economic recovery
you know the uk's had the worst economic
crisis of any major
economy they should be focused on
setting that right not on party
political considerations
um nice answer the question i actually
asked though was
about whether or not why it was that
labour used to think that higher
corporation tax was a good thing and now
you don't
well with respect i just said that we
would welcome
that longer time debate around
corporation tax i just said
that it has been concerning to see how
the consensus party
has pulled us away from the mainstream
on corporation tax but
why are they focused on this now why are
they focused on
increasing council tax directly for
families right now they're focused on it
because the chancellor has said to his
mps
that he wants to get tax changes out of
the way now
so they can have a clear run through to
the next general election
instead they should be focused on
promoting our economy
securing that recovery yes let's have
that long time discussion about tax
particularly to protect our high street
businesses but let's not pretend that
the conservative party is doing this
right now
because they want to secure our recovery
it seems to be driven by party political
considerations
so if rishi cena does propose higher
corporation tax labour's going to
support that vote in favor of it
if we see a long-term plan for getting
our country to a better place
on corporation tax particularly one
which faces up to that enormous golf and
taxation
for businesses based in bricks compared
to businesses based on the internet
of course we will look carefully at that
but what we don't want to see
right now is what the chancellor is
doing particularly in relation
to council tax the imposition of
additional costs
right now at a point when our country is
experiencing the worst
economic crisis of any major economy
so if there's a long-term plan for
corporation tax you'll look carefully at
that
does that mean you'll vote in favor of
higher corporation tax
well we need to look at how this would
be ruled out we need to make sure that
it would be a plan
that would actually make sense for
british business we've got to be doing
all we can to protect jobs and
businesses right now but
as i mentioned before one of the really
big problems with the uk tax system is
that big gulf
between how businesses based on our high
streets are taxed and their business
rates
are a huge problem the chancellor is
kicking the can down the road around
business rates reform now it's not going
to happen
apparently until the autumn that big
gulf between those businesses
and businesses that are largely based on
the internet where corporation tax
is more relevant of course not just the
rate of corporation tax but those
enormous loopholes
that the conservatives have allowed to
develop over the last 10 years
so we would look at any plan very
carefully but we're saying
very directly to the chancellor now
please don't be following
party politics for this budget follow
what is in the interest of our country
and its economic recovery
you mentioned now about the high streets
and the gulf between
online retailers and high street
retailers during the pandemic
does that mean you would support any
taxes aimed at online companies
well we've seen a lot of kite flying
from the government around this
issue and we haven't seen yet any
concrete proposals their digital
services tax really isn't the kind of
robust
change that we need to see to level that
playing field
so we would look at any proposals very
carefully but it's so
important that they do start to level
that playing field we've got businesses
really suffering on the high street
the government's planning changes are
actually going to make that worse i was
astonished to hear
the chancellor say that they would
improve the situation they could lead to
a wholesale
sell-off of our high streets so we
really do need to be getting this right
for the future
um your predecessor john mcdonnell uh
today that told the show last week he
liked to see a windfall tax on companies
who have profited
um in the from the pandemic banks
property developers
tech companies would you support
windfall tax
well actually i'm sorry to sound like a
stuck record but
i believe what the government should be
focused on doing
right now is on protecting jobs and
businesses of course there
can and should be a discussion into the
future about the
nature of taxation but you know we have
suffered
the worst economic crisis of any major
economy in the uk and we're unique in
another way that we're the only country
that right now has a debate focused on
increasing
tax particularly on families that's the
wrong thing to be doing
right now absolutely let's have that
discussion for the future about taxation
but right now let's please have a budget
that's focused
on jobs and businesses um
you talk a lot about debate and
discussion in the future and just trying
to get a sense of what you
would do right now are there any tax
risers
in this budget that you would support
well with respect what i would be doing
right now if i were
chancellor is being focused on securing
the recovery what he should have done in
fact not right now but many many things
on tax rises
it should have been clear about that
sorry he should have been clear about
the continuation
of business rates about the continuation
of the vat reduction he should have
a clear roadmap for the future of wage
support and reform
that system because you know we can have
the chancellor
talking about how he would tax different
forms of economic activity
but if the tax base is shrinking as it
is right now
then that discussion is really at one
remove
from securing our recovery that is what
he should be focused on
um so you seem to be saying that right
now should be focused on on spending on
supporting
and people during the pandemic are you
worried at all about the state of the
public finances so
clearly the chancellor has got his eye
on that are you worried about debt
levels
well of course they're a concern right
now we do have
very low interest rates but it's not
necessarily the case that that would
continue
forever so we do need to have a sensible
approach to this but
you know we've got to focus on that size
of the tax base you know
how many people are in work how many
businesses are operating
right now we've seen that tax base
shrinking we've seen record
redundancies and so it's really
important that we build that economic
activity back up that's what's happening
in other countries
and really the uk is well out of the
mainstream now
with the chancellor's approach so you
don't seem to support tax rises
you also seem to want more spending and
you're worried about the public finances
it sounds a bit like cake and eat it
boris johnson well no that's that's not
right
because we want to see a much more
targeted approach first of all
we've seen billions of pounds wasted by
the government during this crisis the
chancellor at no point has said
that he would crack down on that waste
so it's really important that we do
tackle it but secondly
we also need to see a much more targeted
approach from government if you look at
the business rates holiday for example
in england that's been provided to every
retailer including the very biggest
essential retailers that's been giving
them support that many
simply did not need in labor run wales
they've had a much more targeted
approach that's ensured that actually
support has got
to where it's needed so let's talk about
having a targeted approach
let's stamp out that waste and
mismanagement and if we did that then
this crisis wouldn't be proving
as costly as it is under the
conservatives
okay just finally asked rishi sunak at
the end of the interview about shamima
begum the batman green schoolgirl who of
course
left the uk to join islamic state
do you think it's right that she hasn't
been allowed back to the uk to contest
that decision to strip her
of her british citizenship
well we've had that supreme court
judgment of course it was a complicated
judgment but we respect that judgment we
respect the rule of law
okay uh thank you very much annelise
dawds for being on the program today
thank you
well lots of people will be waiting
anxiously to hear what's on the budget
on wednesday and few people more so of
course than the business owners who have
been hit
so hard by the pandemic we've already
heard about the plans for new grants but
that's just one part of solving a deep
and complex problem and this week i went
on the road to find out more about what
businesses need
the historic town of guildford in surrey
known for its cobbled streets
high-end shops and famous guildhall
clock
but even this affluent high street isn't
immune to the pressures of the pandemic
the hair and beauty bar has been a
staple here for 21 years
but forced to shut its doors for the
third time in the last 12 months
owner gemma is desperate for rishi sunak
to switch on more support
in next week's budget i had a good
successful business
that gave me a nice lifestyle
and i wasn't in any debt and i'd say
now probably at least 35 000 pounds
i owe in rent um
which is obviously not a nice place to
be when you're not used to being in debt
and i'm a personal guarantor of my lease
which means that
you know if the landlords decide to um
pursue me
it could be my house that could go huge
amounts of
stress worry about the future
i do have two young children that i
support
and actually wondering whether or not
it's worth continuing in this industry
because realistically to pay the debt
back
we'd need to up our takings by about 20
a month
and obviously we guarantee that we can
open for the foreseeable future as well
which is quite unrealistic hairdressers
and other non-essential retail will be
allowed to open their doors again on
april the 12th
but for gemma that's just the start of
the fight back
she's also worried about the future of
guilford high street
there are so fewer shops now retail
shops
there's not an awful lot to come to the
high street for
which i guess is the rents are just too
high
and people can't make it work this week
rishi sunak will announce a new 5
billion
grant scheme to help shops pubs gyms and
hair salons like gemmas
all hit hard by the pandemic without
government help like this
the ippr think tank believes almost six
hundred thousand companies
are at risk of collapsing this spring we
reckon
that some forty percent of of the
smallest businesses which are actually
really vulnerable so employ less than 50
people
um have something in the region of less
than three months
cash um to keep themselves going uh
and many of those businesses will be on
the high street
um so it's a really a really serious
situation there are potentially a bit of
a ticking time bomb
um for the economy and many lives and
livelihoods depending on on whether
those
those businesses will make it do you
think that
once things get better the high street
will ever fully recover
well i think we know from the research
that we have done that even before the
crisis
the high streets were under pressure and
and many times centres were feeling the
the impact of online shopping but also
changes in the way that we use town
centers um
and i think that um for for many time
centers the crisis has accelerated these
trends further
um and moved us to our position much
faster than perhaps we would have done
otherwise
the other challenge for for high streets
and for town centres across
the uk is around business rates and we
know that the uk's
land and property tax system is really
inefficient
since russia zunak delivered his first
budget a year ago we've seen the biggest
hit to gdp since records began
a national debt rise to more than two
trillion pounds
for the chancellor the pressure is on to
chart a path to recovery
i think we have got some tax rises
coming down the line but i don't think
we're going to get big tax rises
this time around there's so much
uncertainty about what's going to happen
to the economy over the next year
there's so much uncertainty actually how
much tax we're going to need in the
medium
term and the focus of the movement i
think is getting the economy back on its
feet what i'd like to hear from the
chance there is a commitment though
to getting that uh fiscal balance in the
medium
run so i don't really want him to say
i'm going to be raising taxes a lot this
year
but i do want him to be saying that if
in a couple of years we've still got a
very big deficit which is
adding to the overall debt then he will
do something about it
and be clear that he is willing to raise
taxes if that's what's needed
we've had the road now you've been
mentioning the date in june when it
feels that the restrictions are going to
be
lifting at least most of the
restrictions the government's always
said that that will be data
driven but it seems like they're saying
that it will only be slowed down if the
data
isn't as good as expected do you think
it should also be sped up if the data is
better
than thought i think it's very clear
that if we
um if things move more quickly more
positively than expected if we have
a very high fraction of people
vaccinated and very low levels
of infection then then yes it should be
sped up there's no need
to stick to a date if things go better
than
expected and every month every week of
additional
uh lockdown is costing not just the
economy i mean
it's costing so many people so much in
terms of their
mental health their education their work
and everything else that um
it should be moved as quickly as is
possible uh consistent
uh with um doing it safely and so if we
can do it quicker we absolutely should
throughout the crisis rishi sunak has
enjoyed positive approval ratings but
it's easy to be popular
when you're dishing out money at some
point the recovery process and the
fiscal rebalancing
will have to begin the question is is
now the time
for gemma the answer is no without more
government intervention she worries her
business won't survive
please cut about five percent keep
business rates at zero um for the
foreseeable future
and to intervene with our private
landlords and
our insurers this hairdresser's will
open its doors again on april 12th along
with other non-essential retail
but it's what happens next week that
will determine whether many businesses
like this one
shut up shop for good
my piece there and what businesses want
to see in the budget well someone else
who may have you the view on that
is andy street the conservative mayor of
the west midlands he also happens to be
the former boss of john lewis thank you
very much
for being with us at joining us from
birmingham um we've just
watched a film on the high street it's
clearly a really hard time for so many
businesses and the ippr estimates that
more than half a million
could go under this spring without more
government support what's your analysis
that's uh absolutely right and i think
the wider point is that
we are still in the crisis obviously
there's a road map out of it but you
keep
asking the question should we be moving
to solve the public
finances now or should we be dealing
with a crisis and i'm absolutely clear
on this we have got to sustain
the support for businesses until we get
to the other side of this
and perhaps the thing to reflect on is
all of the things that
the chancellor has already done will
almost be in vain
if lots of businesses fail in the next
three months so i'm categorically in
that camp
and of course that does mean the high
street businesses yes welcome the money
that's been talked about today
but we've got to think about some of the
underlying points as well and of course
that includes business rates involved
um just to unpick some of what you said
there you're talking about the support
needed to continue
otherwise businesses will fail what kind
of time frame are you
um talking about i thought it was pretty
clear from rishi sunak that
you know they want to extend the support
to the end of the road map which is in
june
but do you think that actually some of
the support or needs to actually go a
bit further
well it's interesting because business
is not sort of uniform is it here
so uh quite rightly there's a lot of
talk about the businesses that have been
most seriously affected that's what your
film
just talked about and i hope that for
them it really is a question
of getting to the reopening perhaps a
little bit on that because anyone who's
running a business knows that the period
in which you're
gearing back up is also very vulnerable
in cash flow
so but i'm optimistic that by the summer
we will see that consumer-led
recovery but there are other businesses
where the
other sectors where the damage is much
much lower long-term let's go to the
other extreme perhaps an
aerospace business lots of those in the
west midlands they are not
suddenly going to bounce back they've
still got lots of people on furlough
their levels of demand are very low and
the way they're going to need to come
back
is by investing in new kittens for the
upturn
and that's all about the sort of tax
advantages for them and that is a much
much longer burn that some of those
really competitive sectors
will be able to come back strongly it's
interesting because you're touching
there on sort of long-term
tax reform business rates for example to
help the high street things
directed at certain industries to help
their
uh working climate be a bit more
attractive what kind of things do you
want to see
well i think the first thing around tax
that we're already seeing actually is
the tax on
jobs or the encouragement of businesses
to take more people on
the primary challenge i'll be honest
about the situation in the west midlands
85 000 more people claiming uh universal
credit benefits
than this time last year that is an
enormous change
so the headroom that the chancellor may
still have left
have already i think been applied quite
wisely to some of the business
uh advantages taking on apprentices so
that three thousand pound allowance
there
the kickstart scheme obviously and then
of course what's also
uh being done hopefully around there's a
talk in the papers today about
national insurance holidays for
recruiting so that would all
try to make it more attractive for
businesses to recruit people
but then we're also going to need to
think about what helps companies
invest in the long term and the old the
best
approach there is definitely tax
allowance against investment
what about corporation tax a lot of
discussion around
potential rises to corporation tax do
you think that would be
a good idea to try and get the public
finances in order
well let's take the question a little
bit more broadly then we'll come back to
corporation tax head on
i mean obviously we have got to over
time
address the public finances anyone who
denies that i'm afraid is denying the
reality but as your first question
drought
it's a question of when and it's also
true to say
that we say we've all been in this
together but actually some
sectors have had better times and some
individuals have had better times
so it is going to be necessary to see
some
tax rises in the areas that have
probably done better
so you know the talk about online online
taxes i i do again say categorically
that
is the right thing to do they have had a
good time it is right they
bear a little bit more of the burden on
corporation tax
i would regret it personally because i
do think britain's very competitive
corporation tax has been right
but i would fully accept there are some
really tough choices for the chancellor
and if the end judgment is that's going
to go up a few points
as he's talked about in the papers today
we'd still be relatively competitive
and i would accept that possibly as a
price to pay
um you mentioned online tax and it's a
fiendishly difficult
place to tax and because of the
international uh
global state of affairs and what kind of
things could the chancellor look at i
mean there's for example on the sunday
telegraph today reports of new tax on
online deliveries is that the kind of
thing that you think would work
you could do i mean you could you can
have an online sales tax it could be
really very blunt like that and of
course
the delivery tax has been talked about
but also actually the form of business
rates
would if you just change the balance of
contribution between high street
premises and say distribution warehouses
you can tilt to different sectors of the
economy
so there are ways of doing it um you're
of course talking to us from
birmingham and mayor of the west
midlands and how concerned are you
about the pandemic's impact on the
leveling up
agenda it's really interesting question
actually
because what we have seen is that
pre-pandemic
this place the economy was performing
really well we had the fastest growth of
any region outside london over the
previous 10 years actually record
employment numbers great investment
but very sadly it looks as though we may
be the worst
affected region so from best to worse is
pretty uh
dramatic so there is an effect but what
will
ultimately drive levelling up is all of
the work around retraining opportunity
skills
and we can continue to do that and
actually in the region we've continued
to try to make great progress on that so
if i was asking for one thing around
leveling up
it wouldn't necessarily about be about
roads and bridges and all of that
actually let's really concentrate on the
retraining
of the people who've lost their job and
get them ready for the industries of the
future
and in our case the whole electric
vehicle industry is critical
and of course the digital sector and
just one step i think your viewers have
found interesting
so free all the retraining we're doing
in digital anyone who goes through our
schemes
almost anyone is employed after them
there are still parts of the economy
that are growing and that's where the
retraining needs to be focused
are you worried that the government's
taken its eye off the leveling up agenda
that it talked about so much during the
election
uh no i'm not actually i am
gosh almost superhuman not to have uh
had to move
complete focus to tackling the pandemic
of course and so perhaps some of the
things that we would otherwise have seen
haven't uh come through i i would accept
that but actually
is there an utter commitment to it we've
heard about the leveling up
fund for example the commitment to
infrastructure spend
in the regions is absolutely there i
hope we're going to hear about the towns
fund
that's a good practical frontline piece
around leveling up and as i say
a lot of money is being committed on
this retraining and that
will in the long term be the best way of
raising opportunity in places like this
i asked rishi sunak about the road map
out of lockdown as well he made it very
clear that the dates given are the
earliest dates at which
things can be eased but at the same time
if it's data driven
should they also be prepared to speed
things up if the data is better than
expected we know of course they're
willing to slow things down if things
aren't going
in the way that they want so um
let me try to explain why i i think
what's been
said is logical and um i haven't sort of
had this
described to me by those in central
government but my own working out of it
is
at each stage we have got to assess the
progress
we know that frankly when we unlocked
after the second lockdown
the virus banks back up what did the
wrote the time delays in the roadmap
are to see that we have not got an
increase
from each stage of it and then if you so
if you look at the three weeks then the
five weeks
to me that is logical because if you
act on the next thing before you know
with the lead time around the spread of
the virus what's happened with the
previous stage
you may be making the wrong judgment i
personally i ask for a cautious approach
to this in the west midlands we still
have a pretty stubborn
level of infections about 169 per
hundred thousand
so for us and the overwhelming reaction
from business there this week has been
yes understand why that cautious but
steady approach is there
because it allows us to assess progress
as i've described so we will never have
to go back
at the same time though lockdown of
course has consequences too we just
heard from paul johnson of the
institute for fiscal um studies who said
you know every week of additional
lockdown is costing not just the economy
but it's also costing so many people so
much in terms of their mental health
their education their work and
everything else
it should be moved as quickly as
possible consistent with doing it safely
if we can do it quicker we absolutely
should you disagree then
no if we if we absolutely can and all
the evidence is pointing at that
of course i'm sure no one would wish to
say no to that
what i tried to do was explain why i
think it is utterly
logical that the time delays in the plan
are
as they are i would definitely like it
to go past the goodness
i lead the region that's had a terrible
effect in every sense
but i do think that it is far more
important that we do this
once and for all and get it right and
never risk the bounce back
that we saw actually twice in the second
half of last year
okay andy street thank you very much for
being on the program today thank you
thank you well we've talked
a lot today about the budget if you want
to hear the best bits of our interviews
plus some analysis from me and my
producer matt lavender
about what to expect and why this budget
in particular is so important then do
check out the sophie ridge on sunday
podcast
we record that straight after the show
it will be available from lunchtime
today on the sky news app and on spotify
and apple podcast as well
now away from the budget the labour
party in scotland yesterday elected a
new
leader its fourth permanent leader in
less than six years
and osawa takes on the challenge of
trying to make labour competitive in
scotland again ahead of those
crucial elections in may where the snp
are expected to do
well well alexander joins us now from
glasgow thank you very much for being on
the program congratulations
on your victory now
labour's got a mountain good morning
thank you labour's got a mountain to
climb in scotland
how are you going to start climbing up
look i think the first part is to be
honest and say that
we have got a really bad position within
just now i'm not naive about the scale
of challenge
and that's why yesterday i thought it
was important to say directly
to the people of scotland that they've
not had the labour party they deserve
and at a time of rising inequality
injustice and division
we haven't been good enough and i
recognize that it's my job now to work
day and night to give people the labour
party
they deserve so we can build the country
we need and i actually think coming
through kobud
we have the opportunity to focus on what
the people's priorities are
rather than the old arguments in the old
divisions
it's interesting isn't it because labour
doesn't look quite different to how it
did a year ago
kierstama is very different from jeremy
corbyn of course and you're quite a
different air politician from richard
leonard
and do you think it's fair to say that
labour believes it needs to win from the
center
look i think it's it's it's less that i
think it's more about
looking outwards rather looking inwards
recognizing that whatever divisions we
think might exist within our own
political party or indeed between our
political parties
they pale into insignificance compared
to the divisions and inequalities that
exist
in our society and we've got to reflect
scotland's future and i think the uk's
future and i think at times we haven't
done that
and you mentioned being a very different
leader i don't think that we've had a
leader that
a 37 year old from the west of scotland
that looks like me from
a muslim heritage that in itself i think
demonstrates a very different scotland
outward-looking scotland international
scotland
i should also say that doesn't say
something about me that says something
great about
these people of scotland and i want to
work with all our diverse communities to
rebuild the country that we love
of course a really big part of the
political landscape in scotland is this
question of
independence um if the snp win a
majority
in the elections that are coming up will
they have a mandate for a second
referendum
look i think the first thing to say in
that is there's a poll out today that
that shows that
um yes is not in the lead and so we've
heard a lot about significant polls uh
leading up to this point where yes i've
been in the lead but
i would go further than that i actually
think it's of course it's for the
scottish people to choose
their own future but actually is it the
right thing to have a referendum
and i think coming through the
collective trauma of covet where we've
been separated from our families and our
loved ones
but we've actually come together like a
country like never before
the idea that we come through this and
go straight into a divisive referendum
campaign i just don't think is the right
thing
to do instead i think it's right that we
focus on rebuilding our country
because what people are worried about
right now is they're worried about their
loved ones staying safe
when they're going to get a vaccine
they're worried about if and when
they're going to go back to work
they're worried about their child's
education or mental health they worry
about the planet we're going to leave
our children and our grandchildren
they're worried about the cancelled
operations
or the failure to get a cancer diagnosis
because of a pause in the screening
program
these are all massive massive issues and
i would much rather we had political
leadership that focused on those issues
and tried to reunite our country rather
than divide our country again
and on that i actually don't think even
nicola sturgeon would be advocating a
referendum right now
but i think she's more focused on
healing the wounds in our political
party
than she is about healing the wounds in
the country and we will talk about
some of the wounds if as you say uh in
the the snp but just to uh talk for
a bit more about scottish independence
in that referendum i totally understand
that you don't think now is the right
time for a referendum but if the snp
win a majority in the elections will
they have a mandate for a second
referendum i mean they don't really hide
their support for it do they they call
the scottish national party
yeah they don't hide their support for
it but nicholas sergeant needs to decide
what people are voting on either they're
voting on pandemic records either
they're
voting on government record or they're
voting on whether they want to have
an independence referendum look i i
don't want to commentate about what
happens after me
we aren't um spectators we are
participants and i think this is the
challenge for us as a labour party
is if i believe in something i'm going
to argue for it so
i don't believe that independence is the
right answer for scotland coming through
this pandemic
i don't believe coming straight through
this pandemic and going to a referendum
campaign
is the right thing for us to do when our
entire focus should be on saving lives
and livelihoods
and rebuilding our country again and if
i don't believe in something i'm not
going to argue for it
instead what i say to people is let's
have enough
of the politicians trying to present you
with binary choices whether it is yes or
no or leave and remain
and forcing you to pick a side let's
instead look at what unites us as a
country
and focus on those issues in the next
parliament
okay now a lot of attention has been
paid this week of course to alex simmons
committee
appearance and nicolas sturgeon's going
to be giving evidence next week
if the first minister is found to have
broken the ministerial code as
alexander alleges should she resign
look i think we've got it's important i
think to take
the political parties out of this and
take the personalities out of this
and go and go straight to the points of
principle the points of principle here
are
that two women were failed in terms of
their complaints how do we have a fair
complaints policy here in scotland
how do we respect the primacy of
parliament how do we respect
and not have the misuse of public funds
i think we should be separating the role
of
the person that is the legal adviser to
the scottish government not being the
person that also
leads prosecutions for us in scotland
and on the point of principle directly
on the question you ask
if there is a minister forget who the
minister is or which political party
they are from
if a minister is found to breach the
ministerial code i think people would
expect that minister to
resign and that's what nicholas sergeant
would say if it was a labour politician
a conservative politician or a liberal
democrat politician
so let's take the party politics over as
the point of principle
so just be clear if nicola sturgeon's
found have broken the ministerial code
you think she should resign
well yes i think nikola serger herself
would say if an
opposition politician was in government
and they'd reach the ministerial code
that they would be expected to resign
let's take the party politics and the
personalities that have a disappointing
principle and respecting the office
of first minister are you a bit worried
that uh the fact that
they have had this extraordinary feud
play out in public
and yet they're still polling well above
the other parties above 50
it doesn't seem to have damaged them
well we've got to take part of the
responsibility for that i mean the
reality is we haven't had opposition
political parties that been on the pitch
in scotland and we haven't been the ones
to offer any kind of hope or change to
our country so
we've got to change that and i think
coming through this pandemic i don't
think we can go back to
the politics the way it was before i
don't think we can go back to the
economy the way it was before
i don't think people could credibly
believe that the conservatives can
deliver a recovery that works for
everyone and reshapes our economy
and i think the snp are so blinded by
their one priority
that they can't be the ones that truly
bring our country back together and
rebuild it after covet and that's why we
need a credible labour party that's why
we need to get the labour party back in
the pitch
talking about the ideas that matter to
people the priorities that matter to
people
and therefore seeking to gain support in
the upcoming elections
okay just finally and many of our
viewers may just be being introduced to
you they may not know that much about
you so
to try and help them find out a bit more
about anastama can you tell me something
interesting about yourself
something interesting about myself well
yesterday i was playing in the park with
my uh
see that again sorry so i said whatever
you want sorry the delay on the on the
line
whatever i want well i've i've got a
september football manager
i was playing in the park yesterday with
my kid and he gave me a big thumbs down
rather than a big thumbs up
live on camera and i used to be an nhs
dentist um
and someone i'd say looks like me sounds
like me standing for election trying to
seek the people's support
and i think there's lots of interesting
things that we can have conversations
about on that one so
okay thank you very much for being on
the program today and i'll sell weather
thank you
thank you